so then time to see what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
christina patterson and annabelle denham
the director of communications at the
institute of economic affairs they'll be
with us from now until midnight very
good evening to both of you we'll chat
in a moment first of all let's check out
those front pages for you starting with
the observer leading with a warning from
scientists that falling trust in boris
johnson could harm measures to prevent
the surge of omicron cases and
hospitalizations
well a cabinet revolt over new kovid
restrictions adds to the prime
minister's woes writes the sunday
telegraph
it's a make or break week for boris
johnson says the sunday express with all
eyes on kovid restrictions and an
upcoming crucial by-election
well the mirror has a picture it says
was taken on the 15th of december last
year showing the prime minister hosting
a downing street quiz the paper adds
that according to a source it was purely
a social event the times reports
healthcare staff have been told to start
preparing for the mass vaccination of
primary school children
and the star has a story about former
professional footballer and i'm a
celebrity get me out of here contestant
david giller
and we're joined tonight by christine
patterson and annabelle denim very good
evening to both of you nice to see you
um right lots to get through then uh
this saturday evening why don't we start
with the front of the express uh
christina it's make or break week for
boris johnson it certainly is isn't it
he's got that crucial vote uh in the
commons on monday and then he's got a
by-election to contend with on thursday
yes well nobody can accuse the prime
minister of having had a boring time
recently or of boring the nation
in any way at all i think many of us
never actually want to hear the name the
words boris johnson ever again
what amuses me about the story and to be
honest not very much amuses me about
this whole business but what does amuse
me is that this straw that seems to be
about to break tory mp's back is in fact
about doing things that will keep people
alive
and keep the nhs from collapsing rather
than the stuff that is absolutely
unforgivable like hosting parties in
downing street when the rest of the
nation was in a very strict lockdown and
when people literally couldn't say
goodbye to loved ones who died during
this time so as we know tory back
benches are very very exercised at the
thought of having to wear masks and
possibly having to show coving vaccine
passports and all kinds of things i mean
none of us like these things it's
absolutely awful to think of more
restrictions coming and the idea of any
lockdown just makes my heart sink let's
hope and pray that's not necessary but
it does seem to me that tory mps get
exercised about entirely the wrong
things
yeah annabelle front of the sunday
telegraph
same story pm faces cabinet revolt over
covid rules i mean we know the vote will
go through because because it's got
labour
support but um
they're angry about plan b already the
scientists are saying that plan b isn't
strict enough and we need to go to a
plan c
well yes i think cabinet ministers in
particular are now very worried about
slippery slope and you can't really
blame them given mps haven't yet voted
on plan b and here we are talking about
plan c some kind of tougher crackdown
even a dreaded fourth lockdown so it's
not entirely surprising
um for much of this week we've been
talking about those 60 odd tory mpcs
going who are going to rebel against
one or all of the new restrictions i
think they're taking particular
exception to vaccine passports because
many conservative mps view them as
anathema to a free society um and of
course they haven't worked in a lot of
countries that have introduced them and
there's very little evidence to suggest
that this measure will actually make a
big difference in stemming the
transmission of the conveyor variant in
fact what i've been reading lately
suggests that the r number for omicron
could be as high as four so these
non-pharmaceutical interventions
just simply aren't going to make a big
dent in the number of cases there's also
the issue that
a lot of members of the public a lot of
politicians are very worried with this
narrative that we have to live our lives
or have our lives dictated to us
and it's always framed in how we can
shield and protect the nhs and really it
ought to be about how the nhs can
protect us and i think ministers you
know they are worried about the
increased pressure on the nhs we know
that the nhs runs at very high hospital
bed capacity during the winter even in
non-covered times at the moment it's
about 95 just under 95 percent ministers
some ministers are very worried that
it's going to exceed that um and we are
going to see the nhs be overwhelmed in a
really critical condition so i think
there's going to be a lot of
tug of war in government in the coming
days i think we need to wait for more
omicron data to come through at the
moment it's still very early there are
some positive signs that while it's more
transmissible it's less likely to give
people severe symptoms um so i think
there's going to be a lot of wait and
see but certainly some gloomy headlines
and i don't think it's all together
surprising that some cabinet ministers
are worried about what the implications
might be yeah um and christina uh the
sunday times is uh reporting that uh one
solution is to uh start getting
injections into very young children nhs
staff ready to jab children as young as
five because we know that uh school
children really are driving cases aren't
they do you think this is a good idea
well look obviously i'm no position to
assess whether uh vaccinating children
is a good idea but if the if
if it's been shown to be safer children
and other countries are doing this and
it looks as though the vaccines are
safer children we vaccinate children
against all kinds of other things and
covid is going to be with us forever so
it probably is better that they get
vaccinated when their children rather
than have to go through uh you know
three monthly boosters as it looks as
though we're currently going to have to
do for the rest of our lives so if if
the medics deem it safe i think it is a
good idea because this thing is
incredibly infectious and it's going to
be just past round and round and round
and it doesn't even look as if given
that we know that people can be
reinfected by omicron if they had alpha
or delta or kent or any of the other
variants then we can easily have new
variants every few months and um i
imagine that the chances of children
becoming immune to
the coronavirus um
will be increased if they if they are
vaccinated early i mean nobody thinks
this is ideal but if it keeps if it
keeps them safe and it keeps um our
society safe in the long term obviously
that's to the good but we are also none
of us going to be safe until the whole
world is vaccinated and we are so very
far from that that i'm living currently
in fear that the the the new virulent
and possibly more dangerous annual
variant is going to be our christmas
treat every year and it doesn't seem
like much of a christmas treat to me no
you make a very good point um and uh
finally in this uh in this part the
front of the observer really sort of
summing up what we've been talking about
to a certain extent annabelle uh
scientists fear falling trust in boris
johnson could harm uh the bid to curb
the omicron surge i mean they've done a
very interesting poll which shows that
by a large market margin um that party
or gathering
as it's also known in number 10 has
really provoked anger and touched a
nerve far more so than the barnard
castle
episode or indeed
matt hancock what would you make of that
well i don't think it's all together
surprising because over the past 12
months since the january lockdown was
implemented we have had
these cases of
senior politicians or those who are very
well connected uh finding ways of
circumventing the rules to the point
where there has been this slogan out
there there's one rule for them and
another for the rest of us and this
party just taps into the frustration
that people feel and the fact that
they're worried that politicians
you know hold them in contempt almost um
for
um and that they're not adhering to the
rules that they're setting so i don't
think that it's all together surprising
and of course we're going to hear more
and more there's a story in the mirror
that i know will come on to you later
about these parties and events that were
taking place while the rest of us were
in tier 2 or perhaps even in lockdown
and we were all abiding by the rules and
it's it's immensely frustrating to hear
that those who were setting the rules
weren't abiding by them um i mean i
think that the main headline on the
cover of the observer is quite
interesting just how much is boris
johnson's falling popularity his
punctured credibility and the sense that
many will feel that he won't be obeying
the rules even the rules that he sets
this december you know how much is that
going to affect compliance because the
suggestion here from behavioral
scientists is that the government could
have a real challenge on its hands in
ensuring adherence to the rules and it's
not all together surprising not just
because of partygate but let's not
forget that in december 2020 ministers
told us we'd be free after 15 million
jabs in february boris johnson set out
that irreversible road map and here we
are reversing it so
i'm not altogether surprised uh that
behavioral scientists are worried about
compliance and
news that we've had this week yeah you
mentioned partygate we'll talk about
that more after the break but christina
just just um 20 seconds if you could i
think there is a worry a real worry now
about fatigue
isn't there about the restrictions we
all had our christmases ruined last year
do you get the sense that many people
are saying well whatever happens i'm
going to make sure i see my loved ones
this year
well i haven't i haven't had that sense
particularly in talking to people but i
feel that i really do feel that i i mean
i feel like a mark for following the
rules because i was meticulous all the
way through and i had i've had so little
until we were allowed throughout so
little social life i'm still very
careful but i do see friends and if the
rules change in such a way that i am not
allowed to see good friends after
lateral flow tests in the comfort of my
own home i'm not sure that i'm going to
obey the rules to be honest i mean you
know we were mugs obeying the rules
clearly everybody at downing street was
having parties all the time so yeah i
think this has that story trust yeah
okay all right interesting okay uh let's
carry on talking about parties you're in
the party mood i can see uh christina
with your christmas tree up behind you
all looking very festive and the mirror
which has led the way really hasn't it
on partygate has got another photograph
which it says is that boris johnson uh
holding a quiz it's one yule for us and
another yule for boris uh is what they
say um well i mean what do you make of
this i mean it's it's an online quiz uh
they're all seated they don't seem to be
breaking any rules
well and i don't know what uh i i assume
that boris johnson was staring out at um
at you know could see what was uh
who he was addressing and from the
report that was an awful lot of people
packed into downing street it was not a
virtual quiz and but i mean who's who's
the least bit surprised about this of
course if parties were going on at
downing street and it's very clear they
were going on a lot of course boris
johnson knew about them what i really
want to know about actually what i would
like the metropolitan police to
investigate is the parties that
allegedly went on in his own flat in the
11 downing street flat because there
seemed to have been dominic cummings is
very clear that they took place
particularly on the day that he left and
if boris johnson was having parties in
his own residence uh not just office
parties but in his own apartment um at
the time when the nation was locked down
and not spending time with their loved
ones who were dying then that really is
something that we need to know about i i
imagine he was and i hope we'll find out
and get that investigated by the police
okay annabelle um we know investigations
are going on into into into various
parties do you think they'll get to the
bottom of it
i mean
i think it's unlikely i do i think don't
get me wrong that what they did was uh
absolutely unconscionable um if they
really were breaking the rules and
having all these parties at downing
street while the rest of us were um
adhering to the rules there were people
store terrible stories including in the
mirror last weekend of people whose
relatives were dying in hospital alone
because they weren't allowed to get
there in time to to see them and spend
their last moments with them um and as
number 10 having quizzes and drinks
parties and cheese and wine um you know
it's it's really the optics are
absolutely terrible but the behavior was
absolutely terrible so i hope that we do
get to the bottom of it i'm not sure
it's the best use of of police time to
be investigating this i wonder if there
are other avenues that are worth
exploring but i know christina touched
on this you know dominic cummings sent a
tweet yesterday saying also there's lots
of pictures of parties which will
inevitably get out and the list invite
lists beyond number 10 to other
departments so i can really see this
story gathering steam the house is
rising on thursday but i don't think
this is going to die down even over the
festive period i think that's going to
be a big story yeah just with regard to
this latest story in the mirror uh danny
street have uh issued a statement this
was a virtual quiz downing street staff
were often required to be in the office
to work on the pandemic response so
those who were in the office for work
may have attended virtually from their
desks the prime minister briefly took
part virtually in a quiz to thank staff
for their hard work throughout the year
lots of uh the use of the word virtually
there christina annabelle thank you both
very much we shall speak again